[Music]
like bad guys like you I'd mess it up
every time maybe you just need a partner
feel a chance to practice this follow my
lead
[Applause]
oh you got ant-man in the walls very big
Marvel fans we wanted to know what would
star-lord be doing in the break 14
infinity War part 1 & 2 in the break
between infinity part 1 and part 2
what's star-lord up to yeah you'll know
you'll know once you see part 2 I will
be filmed I'm slated to film guardians
the galaxy vol 3 in January so we don't
know yet who time wise where that lines
up I'm hoping it's not the last you see
me but I can't be sir I've gotta ask you
quickly about the Marvel Universe you
being from master would you be up for
maybe returning in Avengers infinity War
part 2 what do you think you'd be
getting up to I don't know who knows
they've got a good imagination you know
Kevin Feige and Lewis Esposito in
Victoria Lanza over there they know what
they're doing they make good movies well
see if I could contribute anything to
what they were doing I I imagine this
that my brother when the collector
played by Benicio del Toro maybe we see
us together I don't know who knows but
my character can do anything I'm I'm
i've got more superpowers than all of
them put together
you're the Grandmaster and the
Grandmaster you can't kill me I can do
everything I can fly into all sorts of
things and really so really all I want
to do is play games but I could do
anything
hey everybody its charlie you just had
to love Jeff Goldblum reminding us that
he actually is very powerful as an elder
of the universe and he's a brother to
Benicio Del Toro's character who was
last seen during Avengers infinity war
so if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get all the
Marvel videos there's a whole bunch of
new ant-man and the wasp stuff that they
dropped there's an updated description
of the movie that talks a little bit
about stuff happening in the past so
we'll break that down but also Chris
Pratt revealed
what's going on with guardians 3 because
we have a pretty good idea of when those
movies pick up after the events of
Avengers 4 so the updated description
for ant-man the wasp just reads in the
wake of Captain America Civil War
Scotland grapples with the consequences
of his choices as both a superhero and a
father as he struggles to rebalance his
home life with his responsibilities as
ant-man he's confronted by hope Van Dyne
and dr. Hank Pym with an urgent new
mission Scott
once again put on the suit and learn to
fight alongside the wasp as the team
works together to uncover secrets from
the past
so obviously secrets from the past is
the new part of that they're probably
talking about Janet Van Dyne because
they haven't really directly addressed
the idea that he came out of the quantum
realm successfully and that was the
whole thing with hank pym he had to stop
looking for his wife Janet van died
because he didn't think that it was
possible to survive a trip down into the
quantum realm so that sounds like he
gives them part of the idea to go back
down in there and find Janet Van Dyne
but obviously everything we've seen from
the ghost has something to do with
stealing Pym tech that also probably has
something to do with the quantum realm
that's where she gets her powers from so
that all just causes them to uncover
secrets from the past which is also
where Laurence Fishburne character comes
in because in the past he used to work
with Hank Pym he's playing comic book
giant man that's why he had that joke
about being able to grow 225 feet uh
what was your record 65 feet Wow
65 some of the new images that they
dropped to our big high-rez pics of the
quantum realm one of them though this is
actually interesting is ant-man in the
quantum realm from the first movie
wearing the old version of the costume
so this doesn't look familiar here I
think this is Scott Lang from the first
film but remember he was wearing the og
Hank Pym ant-man costume the one that
he's been wearing since civil war has
been the new version of the costume just
slightly redesigned different helmet
different gauntlets so that's actually a
good way to tell where you are in the
timeline because they'll probably be
some flashbacks to explain what ant-man
and the wasp did before they went into
the quantum realm like the og wasp
costume looks like this it looks like
these are flashback scenes because you
see her beating someone's ass in a
warehouse here Marvel is also describing
these tardigrades here in the pictures
you've seen in some of the trailers as
the quantum realm so this is just them
finding out that there's an ecosystem
here I've talked a little bit about the
Microverse and other ant-man the wasp
videos there's just like a universe of
characters that lives down there at that
level but sort of moving into Avengers 4
or guardians 3 territories so Chris
Pratt is obviously promoting Jurassic
world right now Jeff Goldblum's Malcolm
characters obviously in the movie too
but you know what a coincidence we just
had a really big Marvel movie Jeff
Goldblum was just in a really big Marvel
movie last year too so course you gotta
ask him all kind
questions about marble and technically
the Grandmaster is still alive they can
imply that those subjects we're gonna
try and kill him
but even though they made a lot of jokes
about it the elders of the universe do
have legit power like it's actually
pretty hard to kill them I just I gotta
say I'm proud of you all
this revolution has been a huge success
yay us pat pat on the back pat on the
back come on no me too because I've been
a big part of it can't have a revolution
without somebody to overthrow so you're
welcome and it's a tie so when he's
talking about coming back during
Avengers infinity War part 2 that's not
gonna happen
they've already shot the movie they're
editing it right now there will be
reshoots later on but like brie Larson
already shot her Captain Marvel scenes
for that if you're fascinated by the way
movies get made she actually did her
Captain Marvel Avengers for scenes
before they started shooting the Captain
Marvel movie which I know sounds
backwards but the whole thing with
Avengers infinity war and Avengers 4 is
they shot them back-to-back meaning that
they were just ready to shoot the
Captain Marvel scenes for Avengers 4
before they were ready to shoot the
Captain Marvel movie itself so the
interesting thing to think about too is
is her costume that means like you know
she gets her costume by the end of the
Captain Marvel movie but do they tweak
it at all from what it looks like during
Avengers 4 because you look at Black
Panther during infinity war in his
costume does look just a little bit
different from the CG in the Black
Panther movie
[Applause]
[Music]
I think they had to start working on
infinity war before they started working
on the Black Panther movie so that by
the time they got to some of these black
panther shots like where he's standing
really still the easier CG for them to
do they were able to polish it just a
little more so I'm expecting the same
deal during the Captain Marvel movie but
just to reiterate guardians 3 is
currently scheduled to start filming
January next year and then I think it's
gonna be released May of 2020
could be April but I'm expecting may now
spider-man homecoming 2 is gonna be
filming later this summer that's gonna
be another summer movie next year that
picks up minutes after Avengers 4 ends
guardians 3 also probably picks up
relatively quickly after the events of
Avengers 4 because remember the wonky
timeline with guardians 1 and guardians
2 guardians 1 takes place in 2014
guardians 2 even though it came out a
couple years later after a couple of
other movies had already happened was
only a couple months later in the
timeline so the events of guardians 2
like baby Groot is still during 2014 but
you get to infinity wars the reason why
he's teenage Groot is is because he's
had a couple years to grow but let me
know in the comments do you actually
think that Groot will grow back to full
size during Avengers 4 when he comes
back or during guardians 3 there is a
new round of that infinity war DVD
giveaway that's going on all you have to
do to enter that is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video click here
for my new Hulk video and click here for
a brand new Wonder Woman
2 in Titan's thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]